bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo votre
rendez vous de l'actualité européenne
des chaînes parlementaires
dans cette édition direction l'irlande
un pays qui après quatre ans d'austérité
a annoncé il ya quelques semaines sortir
du plan daide mis en place par les
instances internationales
mais le tigre celtique est il sorti de
la crise
pas si sûr mais d'abord l'actualité
l'europe est sous le choc après le
référendum suisse qui rejette
l'immigration de masse alors à cent
jours des élections européennes
est ce une répétition générale c'est la
question de la semaine
un dimanche soir d'hiver l'europe s'est
réveillée groggy victoire par ko un
uppercut venu tout droit de suisse à une
courte majorité de 50,3 % les habitants
ont approuvé la limitation de
l'immigration sur leur territoire par
une votation populaire cette petite
habitude qui a su souvent secoué
l'europe
en 2009 déjà les minarets des mosquées
furent interdits
du coup l'union européenne à trois ans
pour revoir les accords de libre
circulation avec la suisse bien
marchandises capital personnes une
petite sortie du marché unique pour un
pays qui n'en fait pas vraiment partie
dans les capitales des 28 ce café valeur
d'exemple et les cris d'orfraie n'ont
pas tardé à jaillir car ce référendum
contre l'immigration de masse a été
saluée par tous les partis d'extrême
droite ou de droite populiste européen
alors ce référendum une grande
répétition avant les européennes
et pour répondre à cette question
sensible c'est constance le grip que je
reçois bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe du parti
populaire européen vous êtes l'ancienne
conseillère europe de nicolas sarkozy
alors quand vous voyez un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé en suisse sur cette
votation est la manière dont ça explose
et un petit peu au visage des dirigeants
européens
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une
répétition générale à cent jours des
élections européennes
alors je ne pense pas que la
consultation suisse soit une répétition
générale ou une préfiguration de la
consultation électorale européenne de
fin mai 2014
néanmoins c'est vrai que c'est un
message politique fort et un coup de
semonce qui nous est adressé par le
peuple helvétique je ne me cacherai pas
derrière des paravents de juridisme
pointilleux de légalisme exacerbée et je
n'aurai pas un et l'arrogance mais la
condescendance de vouloir envoyer le
peuple helvétique ses chères études ou
vous dire mes chers amis vous n'avez pas
compris
vous vous êtes j'ai entendu les formules
qui m'ont semblé un peu méprisante tirer
une balle dans le pied vous avez scier
la branche laquelle vous appréciez en
démocratie quand le peuple parle
le peuple doit être entendue dans son
jour si jamais marine le pen comme ça à
l'air bien parti selon les derniers
sondages et le premier parti de france
vous serez capable d'entendre le fait
que et bien le peuple à voter contre
l'ump qui a été au pouvoir le ps et
cette europe que jean françois copé dit
on les aime tellement qu'on veut la
changer incontestablement il y a une
forte interrogation dans les opinions
publiques européennes sur le chemin que
parcourt en ce moment l'union européenne
quelle robe boule on
ou avec qui voulons-nous continuer à
cheminer ensemble et pourquoi faire ces
interrogations là qui se traduisent en
angoisse en doute quasi existentielle
nous devons les entendre nous devons les
considérer et nous devons surtout nous
partis de gouvernement partis ayant
vocation à revenir au gouvernement en
france l'ump y apporter des réponses les
entendre avec je dirais considération et
y apporter tenter d'y apporter des
réponses crédibles sérieuse responsable
quelle réponse construire il faut se
remettre de la politique au coeur du
processus décisionnel européen il faut
que les politiques qu'ils soient élus
européens élus nationaux gouvernants
gouvernants de l'europe gouvernants des
états membres remettent clairement de la
politique au coeur des processus
décisionnels n'esquive pas les débats y
compris les débats de fond qui peuvent
poser problème y compris les débats
entre les rations qu'on repousse quand
même aux calendes grecques depuis
quelques mois
calendes grecques je ne sais pas moi je
vous souhaite aux réalisations de
lisieux ont fait les gars faits par la
grèce je ne sais pas très bien ce que
veut dire les calendes grecques alors on
repousse
oui non il y a quand même l'une
notamment pendant la présidence
française de l'union européenne au
deuxième semestre de l'année 2008 un
pacte européen pour l'asile et
l'immigration qui avait été négociée par
brice hortefeux
portée par nicolas sarkozy et qui avait
été adoptée à l'unanimité par l'ensemble
des membres du conseil européen salue
également accueillie avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé et de volonté politique
au parlement européen mais qui tout en
définissant des objectifs très clairs et
des piliers commun pour une véritable
politique commune européenne
l'immigration l'immigration clandestine
qui doit être combattu avec
détermination l'immigration légale qui
doit être maîtrisée qui doit être
choisie a pas subi et bien ensemble de
ses préconisations et l'affirmation de
cette volonté politique sont ensuite
restées lettre morte
effectivement donc on a eu un certain
nombre de pas en avant et puis ensuite
on a un peu oublié sous la pression
quotidienne et bien évidemment
compréhensible de la crise financière de
la crise dans la zone euro et s'est mis
au second plan des préoccupations je
dirais régaliennes qui à mon sens
doivent être dans le débat européen et
doivent être pris en main par les
dirigeants européens
je voudrais revenir sur les
ressortissants français qui travaillent
notamment en suisse les transfrontaliers
ils sont entre 100 et 150 mille selon
des sources
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour eux
aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur le sort
de ces travailleurs frontaliers moi je
serais partie seulement attentive je
pense le web en français également au
sort qui sera fait aux travailleurs
frontaliers
à commencer par les travailleurs
frontaliers français ceux-ci ne doivent
pas rester dans une incertitude et une
insécurité juridique qui alors il
remettra en question donc les les
les acquis si je puis dire de la suisse
qui ne fait pas partie de l'union
européenne mais qui bénéficiait de la
libre circulation
c'est à dire un des capitaux des
services dans l'espace schengen
exactement clairement là en gros on a
quand même entendu des
des phrases un petit peu dur vis-à-vis
de la suisse qui disait donc c'est cette
fameuse guillotine qui siffle hostile
aux y'at-il qui remet en question à
partir du moment où on remet en question
une partie en fait des acquis ça remet
tout en question est ce que ça veut dire
que l'europe va faire un exemple avec la
suisse sachant que à partir de 2017
l'angleterre est un petit peu sur la
même visée de faire un référendum sur la
participation ou non à l'espace dans
l'union européenne
je ne pense pas qu'il va faire de la
suisse en l'occurrence ni un modèle ni
un exemple n'est même faire du cas
suisse un exemple qui serait à méditer
les paroles par les autres encore une
fois il faut raison garder il faut
prendre son temps se garder de postures
intempestives et de déclarations et de
jugements à l'emporte-pièce
incontestablement on est devant un casse
tête juridique qui a évidement cette
fameuse clause guillotine mais les
choses ne sont pas aussi simple que cela
et tout le château de cartes n'est pas
en train de s'effondrer sous nos yeux
d'un seul coup d'un seul
on est français et c'est pour ça que
effectivement la surprise a été grande
parce qu'on n'avait pas anticipé
s'agirait dans les capitales européennes
ni à bruxelles sas en détention on
n'avait pas le
mécanismes juridiques alternatif près
dans les tiroirs
on est face à un casse-tête juridique un
casse-tête institutionnels il faut de
prendre du temps pour voir comment
effectivement éviter une situation qui
pour le coup serait à mon sens
préjudiciable pour la suite du projet
européen qui est ce que les britanniques
appellent cherry picking c'est à dire
que tel ou tel pays viendraient picorer
des cerises prendrait ce qui la range
rejeté de la ranchera et serra et se
mettrait à pratiquer une espèce de
politis roma la qualité rien on prend
voilà on ne prend pas le menu mais on
prend la cafétéria l'europe à la carte
là effectivement pour le coup ça mérite
maintenant du temps et de
l'approfondissement dans la réflexion
parce que il faut qu'on puisse aborder
la question suisse à l'aune de cette
vision globale l'europe c'est pas
d'accord c'est toute la garde
écoutez construction merci d'avoir
évoqué le cas suisse avec nous nous on
continue dans la partie magazine de
cette émission il y a quelques semaines
l'irlande annonçait sortir du plan daide
organisée par les instances
internationales
après quatre ans de crise alors pour
autant est-ce que le tigre celtique
recommence à rugir pas si sûr c'est
faustine saint-geniès qui s'est rendue à
dublin
bienvenue à silicon dox dans le quartier
du canal à dublin
les immeubles flambant neufs ont
remplacé les vieux entrepôts aucun logo
apparent mais derrière ces murs amazon
facebook youtube
paypal tous les géants du web ont leur
pied-à-terre ici à commencer par google
qui ne cesse de s'agrandir
suite à côté aussi appartient à google
suit qu'il est derrière nous et puis
essuya copé nous aussi donc il y avait
continué à embaucher tous les jours ça
va encore - béria
ça ça n'arrive pas une aubaine pour
constances mas s'est expatrié à dublin
qui a perdu son travail en février
dernier g
oui mon cv à jour sur internet et j'ai
été démarché tout de suite donc trois
semaines avoir après avoir appris que
j'étais j'étais licencié le secret de
l'irlande pour attirer les entreprises
son impôt sur les sociétés à douze
ennemis pour cent l'un des plus bas
d'europe
et malgré la crise pas question de
toucher à cette fiscalité très
avantageuse et son concept en temps de
crise la dernière chose à faire dans une
politique industrielle
c'est de créer de l'incertitude c'était
important pour nous de garder un impôt
sur les sociétés à 12 et demi pour cent
il est resté à ce niveau et ne changera
pas quatre ans après la crise
l'irlande est le premier pays à être
sorti du plan de sauvetage de l'union
européenne et du fmi
mais au prix d'une cure d'austérité
drastique le discours officiel se veut
optimiste
pourtant les stigmates de la crise sont
encore bien visibles
après l'explosion de la bulle
immobilière comme ce centre commercial
fantôme sur les docks
et dans la banlieue de dublin on ne
compte plus les rues abandonnées comme
ici à priori rose
diogo s'il a subi de plein fouet la
récession
il y a 6 ans elle était chef
d'entreprise et sa maison valait 1
million et demi d'euros
elle a perdu 90% de sa valeur
les styles comment va-t-il bien ces
temps-ci assieds-toi le père après un
divorce et la faillite de son entreprise
elle a connu une descente aux enfers
j'ai pensé au suicide pendant les six
mois où j'étais au plus mal
je ne peux pas dire que je ne vais pas
envisager j'ai su ce que c'était que
d'être au bord du gouffre j'ai su ce que
c'était que de ne plus avoir aucun
espoir et heureusement j'ai deux enfants
ce qui m'a empêché de passer à l'acte la
banque a fini par saisir sa maison jill
se retrouve avec une dette de plus d'un
million d'euros
pour l'aider dans ses démarches davy
drôle
il a fondé un organisme qui aide les
irlandais surendettés aujourd'hui il y a
deux irlande une qui s'en sortent et une
qui n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux
bouts
les statistiques le prouvent le seul
chiffre qui n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis
le début de la crise c'est bien
l'endettement des ménages
désormais jean n'a qu'un rêve repartir à
zéro
aho j'espère que lundi prochain j'aurai
suffisamment de retard de paiement pour
être déclaré en faillite personnelle la
banque où nous retrouvons constance qui
vite à dublin depuis trois ans et demi
traductrice de formation à 26 ans elle
gagne environ 2000 euros net par mois
avec frédéric une amie expatriés elle
aussi elle voit dans l'irlande un
eldorado réservé aux étrangers
ici les entreprises américaines father
leur siège européen et dans chaque
entreprise américaine on va avoir une
équipe française une équipe espagnole
une équipe portugaise allemande
et donc si on parle une langue
européenne
on a plus de chance de trouver de
trouver un bon travail ici j'ai des amis
qui sont irlandais qui enchaîne les
stages ou les tentatives de formation
pour essayer de s'en sortir parce que à
dublin le travail il n'est pas prêt pour
nous le chômage touche en effet 13 % de
la population est plus du double chez
les jeunes même les plus diplômés
quittent le pays
professeur de finance at unity college
chao larkin voit ses étudiants immigrés
comme chez une colline au jour chaîne
bonjour comment allez vous pas mal on
m'a donc cours en master i lie à presque
100 % des étudiants irlandais qui
partent titulaires d'un master en
finance chine comme il y enchaîne les
petits boulots les entreprises où je
travaillais ont fait faillite
mon patron a perdu son jeu les civils
c'est très dur de se débrouiller ici ma
copine à deux masters et gère un
restaurant survivre en irlande est une
vraie lutte au jury vous voyez c'est un
effet d'optique
l'état veut une belle histoire l'europe
veut une belle histoire et ils vont
travailler que ce soit la réalité
je fais
depuis 2008 plus de trois cent mille
personnes ont quitté le territoire pour
l'essentiel des moins de 35 ans alors
l'irlande est elle en train de raconter
une belle histoire à l'europe pour en
parler je reçois de députés sur ce
plateau philippe lambert ce bonjour vous
êtes député vert vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires économiques et
financières et alejandro cercas vous
êtes député socialiste et démocrate
et vous vous êtes au sein de la
commission emploi et affaires sociales
rapporteur de la commission d' enquête
sur la troïka ce que vous êtes aussi
finalement parce qu'on a deux rapports
sur l'action la troïka au sein de ce
parlement un de la commission affaires
économiques et l'autre de la commission
emploi et affaires sociales
alors messieurs quand vous voyez ce
reportage est ce que en gros il ya là on
n'est pas en train de nous raconter une
belle histoire avec des violons
alexander cercas oui il faudra godet
l'histoire complet parce que nous
craignons beaucoup qu'on va raconter une
partie de l'histoire l'histoire de la
banque
l'histoire des marchés n'est pas
l'histoire des jades normaux et les
problèmes et des chaque jour des jeunes
des chômeurs des malades et tout ça
alors c'est pour ça que nous allons
faire un rapport aussi à la commission
emploi et affaires sociales pour écouter
aussi les caisses qu'ils disent les gens
et l'irlande
l'élan si vous permettez c'est même si
on aurait dit à un reportage sur la
grèce au portugal c'est encore pire
bien sûr et on voit que c'est la
catastrophe sociale et la catastrophe
est structurel ça va durer beaucoup de
temps donc en fait l'irlande nous
raconte des histoires quand on dit c'est
pas juste l'irlande je veux dire à la
banque centrale européenne à la
commission européenne au conseil
européens à l'eurogroupe
on a besoin d'aller raconter une
histoire qui peut quelque part a
posteriori légitime
les politiques d'austérité massifs qui
ont été imposées donc ils ont besoin de
ça on est en année électorale il faut
aller raconter un truc et on s'en fout
de savoir si fondamentalement les faits
étaient l'histoire ou pas l'important
c'est de dire que regarder le premier
pays s'en est sorti soit dit en passant
quel est le critère de succès qu'ils
utilisent et c'est vraiment intéressant
il faut vraiment lire les mots lorsque
olli rehn le commissaire européen aux
affaires économiques et monétaires dit
regardez l'irlande france ô et la
retrouve
et l'accès aux marchés financiers
autrement dit c'est comme ça qu'on a le
critère de succès le critère de succès
c'est l'accès aux marchés financiers
donc en fait au dessus de la démocratie
vous avez les marchés financiers qui
sont les juges finalement de la qualité
des politiques menées et donc de ce
point de vue là l'irlande peut de
nouveau emprunter de l'argent parce que
c'est ça en fait de la dernière émission
obligataire a plutôt bien marché elle
peut emprunter de l'argent donc rentrer
chez vous dormez en paix bonnes gens
tout va bien on se pose évidemment par
la question comme le disait alejandro de
savoir au fait comment ça se fait qu'ils
payent
je veux dire on est passé de 23 %
d'irlande et aux hauts sommets de la
prospérité 23% d'irlandais au seuil de
pauvreté et l'exclusion sociale à 29 %
aujourd'hui 9 % d'une population un
tiers d'une population qui est au seuil
de pauvreté ou d'exclusion sociale
est ce qu'on se rend compte de ce qui
est en train de se passer
enfin l'économie est là pour servir le
bien être des gens mais de ce point de
vue là j'appelle pas ça à succès alors
moi je comprends que les marchés
financiers trou sera un succès
évidemment ils ont été pas investir ils
ont été jetés de l'argent dans une bulle
immobilier ils n'ont pas perdu un kopeck
évidemment c'est un succès pour eux
c'est un grand succès mais donc ce qu'on
a fait c'est privatiser verdon c'est
nationaliser de la dette privée
autrement dit on a permis à des banques
et pas seulement les banques irlandaises
les banques allemandes les banques
françaises et britanniques les banques
belges etc qui ont alimenté la bulle
irlandaise
on leur a permis de se tirer d'affaires
après avoir privatisé les bénéfices on à
socialiser les pertes
voilà alors justement sur vous vous qui
travaillez sur cet aspect en fait emploi
affaires sociales est ce qu on a
complètement oublié les peuples dans
cette histoire on voit jill qui a plus
d'un million d'euros de dette
finalement comme quelle est votre
lecture un petit peu de tout ça mais
écoutez et on a on a fait des solutions
dans notre commission l'a écouté
l'origine internationale du travail le
conseil de l'europe
il les avait demandé est ce que au bout
ça et une demande et quelque chose on le
comité des politiques et sociales qu'il
existait dans l'union européenne
on le comité et d emploi consistait tous
les regards dvd des consultations que
nous avons ne m'étais jamais consultés
c'est à dire c'est comme si c'était
réalité des gens normaux n'hésitez pas
unisyn philippe se sont simplement la
question macroéconomique la banque mais
les gens n'existait pas et ça c'est
contre l'europe parce que l'europe
l'article 7 du traité de fonctionnement
de l'union européenne dit que toutes les
politiques doit être menée pour un haut
niveau d'emploi et à haut niveau de
protection sociale
mais dans ces cas on ouvrir totalement
totalement ils ont travaillé je
travaillais avec l'idée que si la banque
est chauve et tout le monde est choqué
mais je voudrais ajouter les choses
parce que nous n'aurons pas beaucoup
tant il faut le dire les dommages
quand on voit les reportages de
l'irlande se sont pas qu une tourelle
quand on voit tes 25 % de la population
est jeune c'est aussi dans mon pays est
en train de dévaliser sanaa les
doctorats ingénieurs et tout ça quel est
l'avenir de ses deux fils quels sont les
dommages qu on a fait pas si blanc
cautionnerait et structurelle parce que
ils ont détruit beaucoup choses qu'il
faudra reconstruire parce que sinon ce
n'est pas seulement la situation qui ont
marqué ces photographies au csss et film
c'est que ça va durer longtemps
parce que les forces qu'il y avait pour
l'innovation les forces pour l'avenir
l'espoir
la situation en irlande en référé c'est
catastrophique
il y à toute une génération qui n'a pas
espoir pour l'avenir
comment faire des entreprises comme un
oeuf et entreprendre comment faire c'est
pourtant et un tel rassemblement les
banques un énorme erreur même économique
alors effectivement il ya la question de
l'exode et de l'émigration des irlandais
donc on retrouve en espagne au portugal
en grèce il ya aussi un autre problème
qui a été pointée par nombre de
dirigeants européens c'est le problème
de l'optimisation fiscale
bien sûr nos amis irlandais ont réussi à
maintenir coûte que coûte leur taux
d'imposition des entreprises à 12 et
demi pour cent contre parfois plus de 30
% pour certains pays européens
est-ce qu'on a affaire ici à un paradis
fiscal
bien sûr mais je pense qu'il faut être
bon compte il serait de mauvais aloi de
pointer le doigt exclusivement en
direction de l'irlande en ce qui m'a en
ce qui concerne l'optimisation fiscale
je veux dire bien des montages qui sont
faits et qui utilise l'irlande pour
permettre à des gens comme google amazon
et d'autres de ne pas y arriver aux
quelques semaines font appel à des
dispositifs
initiative qui se trouve dans la
législation du grand duché de luxembourg
dans la législation néerlandaise et donc
ça c'est un montage il y en a plein
d'autres je vais dire les paradis
fiscaux en europe se comptent par
dizaines
et donc en effet l'irlande est un
d'entre eux est donc là on peut se poser
la question de la conditionnalité des
aides européennes
on met des conditionnalités sur des
politiques d'austérité on impose
finalement la nationalisation de la
dette privée c'est-à-dire en fait outre
le million que jill va devoir repayer
espérons qu'elle soit déclarée en
faillite
eh bien je rappelle que tous les
contribuables irlandais se retrouve avec
une des publics qu'ils vont devoir
assumer qui est passé de 20 et quelques
pour cent à 117 % du pib et ils sont
partis pour 30 ans et là évidemment
c'est quelque chose qu'on dit moins
facilement et en effet si on veut que
cette dette soit apurée et bien on
pourrait dire écoutez les gars vous
devez imposer les entrepreneurs
l'argument des irlandais cette nuit là
dessus parce qu'il n'est pas à 100 c'est
l'irlande dit nous sommes des favorisés
par la géographie et c'est vrai et c'est
vrai et c'est vrai qu'il irait en
regardant il n'avait pas le temps
d'emmener par un sens et dans un
dispositif fiscal harmonisée au niveau
européen de permettre à des pays
périphériques de compenser leur
désavantage par un avantage fiscal de
manière à remettre les pendules
enfin de remettre les compteurs à zéro
d'avoir un terrain de jeu qui soit
raisonnablement équilibrer le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas ça
chacun essaye de tirer son épingle du
jeu
l'irlande de son côté la belgique du
sien la france du sien de la grande
bretagne et aux ces petits territoires
douleur est donc aujourd'hui si on veut
vraiment convaincre l'irlande de changer
sa politique de dumping fiscal
il faut alors que tous les états
européens acceptent de mettre fin à
leurs propres paradis fiscaux parce que
ce que vous dit c'est que chez nous
c'est 12 et demi pour cent mais ses
douze ennemis % en france nominalement
c'est peut-être 30 mai avec toutes les
niches fiscales mais avec cambadelis
voilà exactement là où il faut être bon
compte alors justement je vous
interromps juste un instant il y à notre
économiste dans le sujet qui avait une
question directe à vous poser on les
écoute
en fin de course
la question clé c'est comment l'europe
s'attaque au problème
écrasant de la leis d'un problème qui
n'existe pas seulement en irlande mais
aussi dans d'autres pays comme l'italie
l'espagne et la grèce et il vaut mieux
faire bouger l'économie que de s'accuser
mutuellement ce qui se passe de mon
point de vue dans les discussions sur
l'europe et sur les réformes de l'union
européenne tout cela avance très
lentement voire pas du tout elles
rendront sakassou en étant justement de
cette question de la gestion de la crise
et de la bête mais la question de
l'allaitement d une fois plus et ils ont
regardé la réalité en dehors des charges
fondamentaux pacem l'espagne c'est un
champion de la dette publique allant de
la crise nous et nous étions au dessus
de la moyenne
maintenant les doubles pourquoi parce
que l'économie a fondu parce qu'il n'y a
pas baissé 1,2 me l'a dit hier les
recettes et qu'est ce que l'on dit ici
la banque centrale de toul et tous les
types et ultralibéraux il faut couper
les dépenses mais jamais et parler des
recettes et des centres est alors quand
l'économie est sous les 0 quand on
détruit l'entreprise par centaines et
milliers comme en espagne quand on a
aucune demande était bien plus parce que
les entreprises n'ont pas avec l'ia
clientèle tout le symbole tombe alors
est il fondé de son austérité dans les
dépenses publiques mais il faut rien
pour animer l'économie alors là des
produits pas simplement horrible avec
aux multiples y avait là deux choses si
on paye la bête comme nous l'avons fait
nous serons payés chaque année 38
milliard d euros pour payer simplement
des intérêts de la dette aux banques et
aux prêteurs internationale si nous
jouons agency dea payer notre dette
publique
trois fois plus cher qu'en france ou en
allemagne nos entreprises sont aussi
chargés au même type à des titres
l'intérêt que les secteurs publics
ils sont dans la concurrence déloyale
c'est pour ça que l'irlandais décès une
chose très intéressante
il disait il ya des sortes et d'irlande
mais je crois qu'il ya aussi des classes
d'euros permettra
db ton pays une voiture et non les pays
les peuples
oui il y en d'autres au contraire qu'on
promettait le produit augmenter l'emploi
augmenter la richesse ont pris des
marchés je parle dans la main entre
autres bien sûr
alors la crise a été gérée pas pour
résoudre le problème avec ce départ
logique contre les le secteur public
pour couper les coûts paix le dialogue
social pour faire des choses
épouvantables alors je devais jouer un
petit peu la provocation
l'islande par exemple a décidé d'annuler
purement et simplement la dette est ce
qu'on peut imaginer la même chose pour
l'espagne pour le portugal pour la grèce
bon je vois qu'une bd pays
on ne peut pas faire en espagne est bien
question qu'on avait tué six espagnols
c'est ce que ça c'était la faillite et
tous les remplaçants sien il ya quelques
années
non non non c'est la faillite et la
france donne aux noix ou la sève et la
grèce voulaient entrer mais pas un seul
euro allemand ou francis maintenant dans
la neige il est offert et le fait les
frais tout neuf et des assurances
mais si on tombait la banque espagnole
parce qu'il est un espagne il est long
mais problème des bi l'immobilier parce
que les banques allemandes les banques
françaises et belges ont barré
s'endetter ça dérange les sauvetages
bancaires européens alors tout était lié
à l'or
sa progression a été comment rembourser
les dettes les équipiers même gravi
fille
en fait sans qui la dette privée passer
au public c'était pour assurer assuré
aussi la banque des pays central des
drops bien sûr et ce qu'est ce qui
passerait quelque est ce qu'il aurait eu
si l'espagne fassent la même question de
la sacer la faillite de la banque
française seulement alors exactement
exactement je pense que la question qui
est posée la question centrale depuis
trente ans la croissance européenne est
motorisé par la dette et on est arrivé à
un point où dans certains compartiments
notre économie dans certains pays c'est
là des publics dans d'autres pays
seraient à des privés qui a atteint des
niveaux ils remboursent
ça dépend des pays c'est en tout cas il
y à une partie de la dette qui des
soutiens pour aplanir leurs envies de
toute manière structurelle mais c'est à
dire qu' il n'y a pas de scénario
macroéconomique plausible qui laisse
penser qu'il sera possible de rembourser
alors qu'elle était
l'alliance est l économie financière
c'est la coupable ddt joliment que
l'économie financière travail pour
l'économie réelle et pour les sociétés
et par le contraire maintenant les rênes
sont dans les mains de l'économie
financière et sont eux qui commandent et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont systémiques et
que s'il tombait tout tomber toulouse il
est aujourd'hui en tout cas je dirai
tout ça il dit ressentir il n'y a pas
moyen que l'école que la finance
resserre l'économie si on ne purge pas
la partie irremboursable de la dette
et là vous n'avez pas dix mille manières
de le faire c'est soit de l'inflation
mais tout le monde sait que l'inflation
est socialement très fruste c'est soit
la croissance mais c'est se dire qu'on
va retrouver des noirs 111 4 5 6 % c'est
une illusion
c'est soit tu es bien la restructuration
de la dette c'est à dire retrouver des
arrangements en prolongeant les périodes
de remboursement réduisant les taux
d'intérêt soit un impôt sur la fortune
tels que thomas piketty il propose 1 et
donc pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi les
produits qui ne seront pas taxés au même
niveau que l'été
oui alors ça c'est la taxe sur les
transactions financières messieurs je
suis désolé c'est toujours trop quoi oui
ce sera l'objet d'un mode bébé la taxe
sur les transactions financières nous
c'est terminé pour cette semaine rendez
vous la semaine prochaine avec ahmed
tazir bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires